hey guys happy day two of our trip and
happy Veda don't even know what day it
is so I've been singing a song and I
don't know if I want to sing it for you
guys because it may be a little not
appropriate but I need to I need to
think about it before before I figure
out if I want to let you guys see my
song Bri loves my song get out of here
I'm sleep bring this really sleepy
little girl this morning
she's right that's one no I can't let
them hear it yet oh my gosh I highlight
I was thinking oh my god latest top hit
on the radio you're playing Aruba okay a
tropical a beast guys that could be us
but you playin and sleeping okay
whatever
are you know budding out there it is
morning what element of you think she's
gonna come out of really I'm looking
body it's gonna be this look oh my god
she's probably crying somewhere like in
a corner breathe where's she at
does she message us
I saw the butt cheeks she liked the one
what elevator with like 30 people and
then I got off the first floor it
stopped being in it well I'm see me too
we're gonna have to get a little omelet
here I'm gonna Callisto day everything
I'm gonna be documented on video I look
homeless get me out of here I'm just
gonna shake shake shake shake nice
chunky steering yeah I'll do it I want
more food I basically just feel brave
look at you shoveling over there I got
friction to the table but mostly myself
look at that snapchat really good fresh
breeze get more waffles don't do it but
I just want the whole thing no do it I
will
well you're not going to do it honestly
you've done shots of alcohol way worse
than that this is not alcohol this is
like this
like myself problem that's good do it
guys if Jenna does this go subscribe to
her Channel Oh focus on subscribe next
time I'm supposed to video so what's the
point
that's it one serving size it's not even
a serving good 200 no 50 bucks it's all
you more than any more than a $50 really
I know maybe wait no wait I don't think
right now 1 100 $100 okay who's gonna do
it for a hundred bucks out here I'll
shake shake shake shake shake
don't hurry up ready go funny
my mouth
for a year given that milk my friends in
college got a nice tomato I'm cooking
take all sick of that I'm telling you
sir help you
I'm really sorry
I really miss with help they're
refreshing mint you happy the proof is
in the pudding Bri oh thank you hahaha
my ticket so you see you know I may get
two hundred or you lose it and it was
all for nothing maybe I'll do fifty good
post that on snapchat give them the
proof waiter let's get to see it right
now no don't put clothes on yeah then
you get more money more money no clothes
I'm dying bright thanks for really
making my morning we're now setting up
for the ALS ice bucket challenge and I'm
really excited I'll show you guys in the
real video but for my donation I'm
actually donating to a family who's from
my hometown in Pittsburgh who I'll be
directly donating to I also put a link
in the description if you guys want to
donate to them as well so we're gonna do
our ice pack a challenge right here
we've got so many cameras going right
now let's just hope it works
record record yep I'll just put this one
do you think it'll bite me do you think
it bites
here get go get brie go get free get
free in she's over there she's been
getting oh yes
the flag on oh my god I'm skew she
hasn't replied baiting so we gotta go
get free get her get her she's right
there just didn't get it away from me
come on she has help wrong way wrong way
schmear I sort of got a good move
his name is Sam it's okay he's fine he's
a friend come on just come here bud
let's go go get Brianne she's gonna do
anything he's not vicious he's like a
friend oh boy
what time is it Oh time full risotto
do-do-do-do-do I don't like it we have
to be quiet like I'm really
uncomfortable I'm being quiet
yeah
I can't act
it was a time for possession I might do
a risotto dance actual if you want to
see my risotto dance it's on vine right
now so go look at it I accidentally
posted the risotto risotto but without
the mushrooms across the way you can
make that too two risotto no mushroom
right what are you gonna get it was Oh
tonight okay the tenth episode Oh guess
who never said a Bri time for pepper and
girl yeah we should shop after we've the
money okay great idea great idea win
money go should be that's what I do at
home why would I wear money because you
know I buy a gun shiny shimmering
splendid okay I think this is going to
bring this blog to an end I'm not really
sure what we did today okay we did bring
to the Tabasco challenge we also did the
ice bucket challenge which I wash I did
the wine bucket challenge oh maybe I can
show you though haha okay ever done like
hats like this bag come look at this
real cute donor were cute it's cute he's
cute
okay I'll see you guys tomorrow